"Vous dégagez, restez pas dans
nos pattes, c'est pas le moment!"
Contrairement à Maria Bodin, Yvette elle, est
bien réelle. Avec ses frères Camille et René,
ces 3 agriculteurs de Dolus-le-Sec sont devenus
les héros du film documentaire de Silvestre
Chatenay, qui n'est autre que leurs voisin. En
passant ici, ça me rappelait ce que je voyais
chez ma grand mère. Donc j'ai trouvé que c'était
une chance, une opportunité de pouvoir filmer ce
mode de vie qui est un petit peu comme par le
passé mais qui est aussi plein de modernisme
parce qu'ici on travaille un tracteur moderne
etc... Le réalisateur a suivi au plus près la vie
de la ferme de la Giraudière entre 2005 et 2006
pour saisir le quotidien de la famille Trio. En
tout 50 heures d'image condensées en 1h30 de film
qui témoignent de l'authenticité campagnarde bien
loin de la caricature des Bodin's, et encore plus
éloignées de l'agriculture moderne. C'est-à-dire
pendant un an je suis venu régulièrement voir
ce qui se passait et parfois il se passe rien
d'extraordinaire et pas soit il s'est parfois
il se passe des choses très chouettes comme la
naissance d'un petit chevreau. En fait il
se passe toujours quelque chose à la ferme
après on capture pas tout il faut faire un
choix. Bon je suis pas "amateuse" de cinéma
puis... non mais ça c'est la réalité, c'est bien
fait quand même. Dommage que bon, c'est dommage
que maman soit plus là. On a mis dans le film
on s'y attendait pas, c'est vrai que beaucoup
de gens ça les a marqués aussi. Des moments
d'émotion inscrits sur pellicule pour Yvette
qui en un mois s'est retrouvé propulsé icône
du lochois. A Loches le film a déjà enregistré
1700 entrées pour à peine 7000 habitants
"Hier je suis allée à Loches : tiens v'là Yvette,
tiens v'là Yvette ! C'est le film, faut aller le
voir, on l'a vu, c'est bien...Plein de choses.
Pour l'heure 7 copies du film
sont en circulation, 2 à Paris,
les autres en Région Centre à Blois,
Vendôme, Loches et Amboise. A noter vous
pouvez découvrir Yvette sur grand écran à Tours
jusqu'au mardi 12 août au cinéma Les Studio.